in this video we're going to show you
how to do with sinus discomfort there
are certain acupressure points that you
can work on to help someone breathe
through their sinuses so okay so let me
just wear these so I could see what I'm
going to do to you all right so when you
fix sinuses oh sorry I can't see you see
those things we're going to use this
acupressure device and the way you're
going to do it is this is like a tripod
and you know I'd like to use the widest
ones and we just place it right on the
back of the chair and she sits back and
there's six actually there's seven
vertebra on your neck and you're going
to push this out the one the second one
not the first one so this little device
underneath here is not going to
necessarily lean back all the way is not
going to be right underneath the ox of
the skull keep laying it's going to be
right down probably a half an inch down
right there so we're going to hold that
pressure right here and then she's going
to like lean back on a tall back chair
you can do this on your bed you can do
it on the couch and you want to put
pressure on the second vertebra and the
longer she holds this the more that
she's going to breathe and it's going to
open up the sinuses I would recommend
doing this for like two minutes
depending on the size of your body you
may want to use a slightly more narrow
one so try that how was that is that
better or worse better okay so because
of her neck being a little bit smaller
we're going to go ahead and use the the
smaller width and that's how you would
do the sinus acupressure